hermit Dylan is the founder of the
Dillon Law Group she joins us tonight
her meet I mean this is clear even
to the president of Mexico
it's clear to everybody Tucker and I
think it may even be clear to members of
the grand jury in New York and I think
that's why we saw not the expected
indictment come down today but rather a
cancellation of today's session now in
New York the grand jury meets on Mondays
Wednesdays and Thursdays typically and
they're on call for tomorrow so it's
quite possible that people are reading
too much into this and tomorrow we'll
see what was meant to happen today but
some of the leaks that we've seen out of
the proceedings and out of the DA's
office suggests that the D.A is getting
pushed back from the grand jury and that
may lead to the that may be as a result
of the testimony of the witness that you
had on your show on Monday Robert
Costello who testified that you know he
had evidence about Michael Cohen's
credibility that had not been presented
to the grand jury and so if I were a
grand juror and I heard that hundreds of
documents that impacted on the outcome
of this case had not been presented to
me by the D.A I'd have some serious
questions and so I think that's maybe
what happened happening and so far
Michael Cohen had bragged that he was
going to be coming in to testify as a
rebuttal witness but that did not happen
so maybe that's going to happen tomorrow
we just don't know so tomorrow afternoon
there'll be another session of the grand
jury we'll see what happens the letter
that you showed earlier just now I think
it goes to Michael Cohen's credibility
as does just about every piece of
evidence we've seen so far which Michael
Cohen should the grand jury be believing
and I think that's really the import of
that not what really happened but rather
The credibility of the two witnesses
and Stormy Daniels
a super quick question people always say
a grand jury will indeed a ham sandwich
they always return an indictment how
weak does your case have to be for the
grand jury to bulk
uh it has to be really weak that adage
has generally held true over the years
uh it's a majority of 23 that has to
vote on this they have been spending
countless resources and years in this
Witch Hunt Tucker and so this is the
best they can come up with two very
discredited Witnesses with contradictory
stories both of them repeatedly
documents that contradict the case the
case itself not being a crime regardless
of what Michael Cohen pled guilty to
under duress as Robert Costello showed
so if this is the best they can come up
with after 11 million documents have
passed hands and investigations about
Donald Trump I think that shows you just
how far and how low they're willing to
sink to try to get him which as I said
before is election interference in my
opinion yeah I mean it's a Manhattan
grand jury you know
it's amazing army thanks so much great
to see you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else